[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi and welcome
to episode number 137
of the weekly--
no, wait-- daily--
MELANIE WARRICK: Daily.
MARK MANDEL: --daily episode
of the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
We are here live on floor
one of Moscone West--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Pseudo live, but yes.
We're recording as we
speak, but we're also
putting this out the day after.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: But as always,
my name is Mark Mandel,
and I'm here with my
colleague, Melanie Warrick.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi!
MARK MANDEL: How
you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
I'm good.
It's good to be here, and if
you're here, if you're at Next,
you should definitely
come by and say hi to us.
Because we are here at Moscone
West on the first floor,
in the midst of all the various
booths that are in the space.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
we're going be putting out
daily episodes, so look forward
to those, talking about some
of the keynotes and chatting
with people on the floor
and doing interviews and
all sorts of good stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: So what's been
your favorite stuff, Melanie,
so far?
MELANIE WARRICK: So far, day
one, a couple of the things
that I like that stand out are
around AI and around security,
especially seeing
that AutoML is now
going to be part of Translation,
as well as Natural Language.
That's pretty exciting.
MARK MANDEL: That
is pretty cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah!
What about you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm really excited
for GKE On-Prem,
Google-configured Kubernetes
that can be deployed anywhere.
So we know I'm a
huge Kubernetes fan,
but I think this is really
going to expose and expand
the abilities of Kubernetes
to be run a lot of places,
especially as we're providing
some nice multicluster
management solutions.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
Well, I think it's
time for us to go chat
with a couple of the folks
we've got lined up for today.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
we're kicking this off,
day one at Next, with
our wonderful Melody
Meckfessel, who's the VP
of Engineering at Cloud.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Thank
you so much for having me.
I'm really happy to be here.
MARK MANDEL: So lovely
to have you here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wonderful
So, Melody, I know you are
doing the keynote on day three,
but, you know, to kick us off,
what have you been enjoying
the most about Next so far?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Wow.
Yesterday I spoke at
the community event
and started talking
about what we're
launching this week
around DevOps tooling,
for developers using
Google's Cloud Platform.
And it was just awesome
to get questions
from the community around the
things that were on their mind.
They gave some great
feedback for me
and my team to take action
on, and you can just
tell people are really open
and curious and wanting
to learn what's Google doing
for developers and operators,
but also how they
can contribute.
And I think that's a big part of
what inspires me with the work
that we're doing today in GCP.
MARK MANDEL: How
can they contribute?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
[LAUGHS] Well, you
know we talk a lot about
Google Cloud Platform being
an open cloud.
And so from a
developer-- you know,
there's a platform aspect
of that, which means
open APIs and open protocols.
But there's a
developer and operator
or human-centered
perspective on what
it means to be an
open cloud, and that
means having the
freedom to choose
what makes you most productive.
And I think about it in
kind of three aspects.
From a tooling
perspective, for things
that need to scale and
work well on the platform,
they're going to be
GCP products and we
have several that we're
announcing this week.
Beyond that, open
source tooling.
This is a direct way that
developers and operators can
contribute, and we have
some great open source
tools that we work on with
partners and other enterprise
companies.
And then the final
thing is partners.
So developers and operators
working with partners,
we want to make sure they
work well on the platform.
So it's kind of this combination
of GCP tools, open source
tools that developers
and operators contribute
to, and then our partner
products that work really well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Why do you
believe in an open cloud?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: You
know, it's fascinating,
but when you come
back to the humans,
the developers and operators
that are using the cloud--
we've done some research on this
topic around both productivity
and kind of what's
happening in the ecosystem.
65% of developers
we've surveyed say
that they have freedom to choose
what makes them productive.
So think about that.
If the developers and
operators are choosing,
that means that they have
autonomy and they have freedom
and they have a voice.
And so our job within GCP, and
specifically in DevOps tools,
is to enable them to be
productive and maybe,
you know, just a
little bit happy.
As developers and operators,
we keep raising the bar, right?
MELANIE WARRICK:
What, happiness,
when you're developing?
I didn't know that's a thing.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: [LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So what is Cloud
Build and what is Stackdriver?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Great question.
Cloud Build is a continuous
integration and delivery
platform.
It's a way to automate
the build and test.
So once you have
your code written,
this is a way to build
and test and make
sure that you're
sending something out
to your users
that's high quality.
It includes things
like security baked in.
We have vulnerability
scanning features
to check and see if there's
any issues with the images
that you're releasing.
We contribute with
Netflix to something
called Spinnaker, which
is part of Cloud Build.
It's an open source
deployment platform.
So it's just-- again, if
I come back to the humans,
I want to get features
out to my users.
I want to get them out
safely and securely,
and I want to move as
fast as I possibly can.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And these-- just in
general, these sort
of continuous integration tools,
these tool aren't specifically
container based, they can
be used in any Google Cloud
Platform tooling?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah,
we support most aspects
of the Google Cloud Platform and
integrate well with Kubernetes.
All you essentially have is
you can set up your cloud
build and be good to go.
You mentioned
Stackdriver, Melanie,
I wanted to come back to that.
So there's the build and
test and release aspect,
but there's also once your
service is running on Google
Cloud Platform, how do
you monitor and get alerts
and understand what's
happening with the service
through logging and features
like error reporting?
So we are continuing
to evolve Stackdriver
to be the set of products
which allow operators to move
at the speed of Google SREs.
And I'm really
excited, on day three
I'm going to be talking through
some features around our APM
suite, and this really gives
both developers and operators
insight into how to
debug their service,
tracing, and profiling
their application
to do optimizations.
MELANIE WARRICK: All very vital
for performance, for sure.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And make sure you
check out the day three keynote
for that very reason.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: That's right.
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
Well, any other resources
that you recommend
for those that are
interested in learning more
about contributing?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: You can
go to cloud.google.com.
Under the DevOps
Tooling we've got
docs, we've got
ways to contribute,
got thriving open source
communities with Go,
and we've contributed
significantly to Open Census.
So there's so many ways
to contribute and have
a voice in what we're building.
And just one final
thing I like to say,
a key part of what
we've learned at Google
is about how to have
a healthy culture
to support developers
and operators.
So on day three, I'm
going to talk and share
some of the things that
we've learned that really--
not just with the tools,
but with the culture
and the tools combined.
It's really magic for
operating at scale
in a safe and secure way.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
looking forward to that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Before we run away,
favorite thing
you've seen at Next so far?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: I don't know.
Just a lot of tweeting and a
lot of community engagement.
I can't keep up with my
Twitter feed right now.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: A good
problem to have.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
is a good problem.
Well, Melody, thank you so much
for joining us and helping us
kick off our day one of Next.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Thank
you so much for having me.
Have a great Next.
MARK MANDEL: So I want
to say a quick thank you
to Pavan Srivastava coming to
join us today from Deloitte
here at Google Cloud Next.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA:
Thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: All
right, fantastic.
First of all, before
we get started and talk
about Deloitte, tell us
a bit about who you are,
what do you do with Deloitte?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Yes,
so Pavan Srivastava.
I'm a managing director in
our technology practice.
I've been doing technology
consulting for the last 20
years, and predominantly focus
around any of the emerging
technologies and how do we
deploy technology to our about
500 clients, leveraging
our industry experience
and challenges that our
clients are facing everyday.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
So what is the partnership
that we currently have
between Deloitte and Google?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: At a
very broad scale, today
we do all sort of co-innovation,
all sort of go to the market
together, mostly focus around
implementing technology
solutions for our clients.
Definitely, Deloitte goes into
market by industry, by sector,
and we leverage Google
Cloud technology
to implement those
technologies at our client
to solve those challenges.
But more importantly, I'm
focused around our enterprise
client and predominantly SAP
as an enterprise solution
and the goal, and
how best we can
leverage Google Cloud
Platform and other technology
as well as SAP being the core
to help solve any problems.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I think we just saw
Diane on stage, too,
just mentioning how important
it was relationships
like this exist.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA:
Yeah, absolutely.
It was really exciting.
I was hearing keynote and
two things that came out
of the keynote, which I
was really super, super
excited about.
One is [INAUDIBLE]
coming on and talking
about how he's excited about
this APN Google partnership,
and that really
means a lot for us
because our clients
are also expecting
us to play in this
ecosystem with SAP
and the leading cloud providers
such as Google Cloud Platform.
So having SAP's commitment
to Google really
means a lot to us,
right, and that's
why we're all so
excited about it.
And the second thing, Diane
Greene mentioning about system
integrators playing a major
role in helping Google
and the client do it
all these technologies,
and Deloitte is one
of the leading system
integrators in that space.
So definitely excited about
taking this to the next level.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, anything else
at Next that you've
seen so far that
you're excited about
or that you're
looking forward to?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Absolutely.
The Cloud is a long
journey, it just started.
Our clients are getting used to
enabling their businesses using
their ID in Cloud, right.
This is just a beginning
from our enterprise client,
but the art of
possibility around
the digital transformation that
we're going through with SAP
and leveraging things
like AI, machine learning,
would be very important.
Our clients are expanding their
businesses, more automation,
more staying closer to their
customers is important,
understanding how
their customers buy,
understanding how their
business is performing,
Analytics platform,
BigQuery, all
of those things
are really exciting
and all of those exciting
announcements for us.
MARK MANDEL: If people
want to learn more
about Deloitte and Google
Cloud, where can they go?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Well
I think, first of all,
this last week there was
a media press release
where we have announced an
alliance with Google and SAP
to help our enterprise
client to adopt
Google technology
and [INAUDIBLE]
their digital
transmission journey.
Definitely look out for a future
announcement around that idea.
This week at the
Google Next conference
in our booth you
can go and see a lot
of new innovative solutions
that we have built. One of those
was invoice management
solution that
was also displayed in Google
booth and Deloitte booth
at Sapphire, but are also
being displayed here again.
There are other
solutions around BigQuery
that we are presenting
at our booth,
so you should definitely be able
to go and take a look at it.
We have experts at the booth
who can talk and tell about what
we are doing together
with SAP and Google
around this enterprise--
intelligent enterprise.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us today
on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, thank you.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: My pleasure.
MELANIE WARRICK: So we're
joined by Sandeep Dinesh, who's
one of our colleagues,
and we're going
to talk about Open
Service Broker.
Hi, Sandeep, how are you doing?
SANDEEP DINESH: I'm
good, how are you?
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: How's
Next going for you?
SANDEEP DINESH: Next is going
great, it's a lot of fun.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah?
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, tell us
about-- what is Open Service
Broker?
SANDEEP DINESH: So
Open Service Broker
is an idea of using
services outside
of a cloud native cluster--
natively in that cluster, right.
So let's say you're
in a Kubernetes world
and you want to consume
a service from your cloud
provider, just
like Google Cloud,
and maybe like
Pub/Sub or Spanner.
You can connect to
it without having
to go to the Google Cloud
page or something like that
and provision it.
You can connect to it natively
in your Kubernetes cluster.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: How does that work?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so
basically there's a service
catalog and the broker itself.
And the catalog will have a list
of all the different services
that are available
to you, right.
So let's say you want
to browse the catalog.
You see oh, this Pub/Sub thing
looks really cool, great.
And then with the
broker, you can actually
provision a Pub/Sub
instance and then
connect to it without having
to actually run any G Cloud
commands or anything like that.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we
were talking a little bit
before we started
recording about how
this is relevant in relation
to the On-Prem with GKE.
SANDEEP DINESH: Definitely.
MELANIE WARRICK: How
does that relate?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so
with the GKE On-Prem stuff,
you can also use
the service broker
to connect to this Google
Cloud Services natively, right.
So let's say you
want to use Spanner
with your On-Prem cluster.
With the service
broker you can actually
go ahead and provision
a Spanner instance,
get the credentials and
things like that natively
as Kubernetes secrets, mount
them in, and then start
using Spanner in
your On-Prem app
without having to, again,
touch Google Cloud.
As a operations
person, I can just
use the service broker 100%
to provision my Google Cloud
services.
And even better, because
it's an open service broker,
you can actually
provision services
from other providers as well,
all natively, which is great.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
All right.
Well, before you run
off, favorite thing
you've seen so far at Next.
SANDEEP DINESH: Ooh,
the bunch of clocks
that don't tell the right time.
I love that.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
always very helpful.
Well, Sandeep, thanks
so much for coming by.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah.
Thank you all so much.
MARK MANDEL: Super happy
to have Raejeanne Skillern
here from Intel, one
of our favorite people
and favorite groups.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: Thank
you, it's great to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK: So tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do.
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: So I run the
cloud platform group at Intel,
and that's within our
data center group,
and basically all the products
and technologies that we create
that go into the world's largest
cloud providers like Google,
I run that business.
So from developing
new technologies
to creating solutions and going
to market with our partners,
that's what I focus on,
growing and accelerating
the public cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
So what are you talking to
developers and operators
here at Google Cloud Next?
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: Well, we
have a lot of announcements
that we've been working
on, and actually we're
really just trying to highlight
the results of our 15 year
engineering partnership
with Google.
It started way
back in 2003, when
we did the first performance
optimization of our processor,
and we've been doing a lot
of customization since.
And two years ago, we
announced Alliance.
So this is really an
opportunity for us
to show people what we can do
when we put our engineering
power together.
So from custom SKUs that
they use in their data
center to new
services that they've
created that take
advantage of our latest
and greatest Intel's
own scalable processor,
code name Skylake.
They did a lot of optimization
around that product,
as well as we announced a
three way partnership with SAP.
We are releasing a new
data center technology,
called Intel Optane Data
Center Persistent Memory.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: It's
a brand new revolution
in memory technology.
It's not just DRAM.
It can perform like DRAM, but
it's got persistence in it.
So you're putting a
persistent memory technology
in the [INAUDIBLE]
slot, which means
you have faster access to
that data in perpetuity.
So faster restarts, you can also
do larger in-memory databases,
and it's perfect for
the SAP platform.
And that's why we
partnered together.
So when we release
those technologies,
Google will also release
new services that
are built on this technology.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds pretty amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: It does.
Is there any specific
services right now
that are on the roadmap?
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN:
Well, they're
going to be releasing it.
They're going to announce
that by the end of the year
they'll go into alpha
on this service.
But because it is a little--
we haven't announced
the technology and it is
a little bit out in time,
the details are kind of
saving for the big release,
the big reveal later this year.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That makes sense.
MARK MANDEL: Fair enough.
MELANIE WARRICK: Any
resources or places
that people can find
more information?
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: Yeah.
So in the blog that
Google released yesterday
talking about this
new service, there's
a link that you can register
and they'll give you
more information about the
service and availability
and when it's ready.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
We'll put a link
in the show notes.
MELANIE WARRICK: We will.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
Before we run away, what's
been the most amazing thing
that you've seen so far?
What's got your interest piqued?
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: I think just
the growth of this conference.
It's just amazing to
come back and just see.
I think there's over
25,000 people here.
I feel like it's taking
over San Francisco.
And the reason I
keep hearing it--
I keep hearing in conversations
or seeing it in tweets--
it's because it's
a geeky conference.
They get really into the details
of what the technology is,
the change they're driving.
They have incredible
demonstrations of--
I mean, I was just watching
the Google Mail's self-compose
and recheck grammar.
I need that now!
MELANIE WARRICK: So do I.
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: Those
kind of simple things
that aren't very simple to
create, to the power of AI,
and Diane Greene talking
about how it's the number one
platform in health
care, and just
the wins that they're getting.
So it's just that growth.
Everybody knows Google
globally as search,
but really watching the power
of G Suite and the Google Cloud
Platform take off is impressive.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, thank you for
joining us today.
We really appreciate it.
RAEJEANNE SKILLERN: Yeah,
it was a lot of fun.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so much.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thanks for everybody
for coming out and
chatting with us.
This is a good start to
Next, our first day out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And yeah.
We're looking forward
to Next day two.
MARK MANDEL: Day two, yes.
And make sure to
tune in tomorrow,
and we'll have more interviews
with people on the floor.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
See you then.
MARK MANDEL: All
right, see you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]